l'humanité au cours de son histoire n'a
fait enchaîner d'horribles catastrophe
les unes après les autres
moi j'adorais me réveiller comme par
magie dans un monde meilleur
qu'est-ce qui te fait croire que le
monde sera meilleur
l'énergie solaire continue à tenir
beaucoup
d'humain en marché sur Mars nous avons
vaincu le cancer
et pourtant chaque réponse a porté
soulève une nouvelle question
faites donner un scoop sur le
réchauffement climatique aucune
importance à la fin du siècle on sera
plus là on va tout louper mais on se
marier dans nos magnifiques cercueils en
or
c'est pas la vie qu'on avait imaginé
un homme dont la maison est un feu et
généralement ouvert au négociation
[Musique]
nous sommes chez nous notre planète et
notre seul et unique refuge
il faut voir le changement climatique
comme un ours en fait notre planète est
au centre du ring et combat l'ours
depuis des décennies
ici il nous a bien défoncé la gueule
et si on était capable de développer des
technologies qui nous permettraient de
survivre peut-être même de prospérer tu
ne sais pas ce qui va se passer
ça se passera pas comme tu l'espère
ça je te le garantis
[Musique]
tu seras plus en colère à propos du
passé
l'avenir c'est maintenant
ce serait dangereux qu'elle reste à
Miami votre mère me dit qu'elle a une
sœur à Chicago je crois que tu détestais
ta sœur il fait beaucoup trop chaud pour
détester qui que ce soit ces temps-ci
marche à
[Musique]